How is the woman's exhaustion
? It's still okay, I'm feeling good.
I'll show you how to use the wheel don in this condition
.
I didn't see it, but there aren't many people who have opened their eyes.
I wonder if I can be
my dad
.
It's rare that my dad got hooked and I'm aware that if you keep going like this, your
body and chakra will be exhausted considerably
.
It ’s okay because
I ’
m not really too enthusiastic. Even if I ’m not
so impatient,
I do n’t know when I ’ll meet a strong enemy again, but I ca n’t afford to be messed up
.  Now that you can be an employee like a dad,
the story is like banging,
understand what that means, ask me, Sakura
There's nothing you're worried about
[music]